the signs of battle are all around and
this in the middle of a residential area
which both sides agreed they'd stay out
of it was meant to be a buffer zone
keeping the rebels and the Syrian regime
apart and protecting the civilians it
very definitely isn't that the rebels
have made a string of territorial gains
and the regime forces are lashing back a
lot of action going on a lot of still
and a tank on fire so the rebels and the
regime and helped by the Russians and
the Iranians are really battling over
territory for this final rebel
stronghold and the rebels aren't giving
up without a huge fight but we've been
spotted by the regime now we are the
target which clearly marked as media and
I'm wearing a Muslim dress run with us a
to civilian activists and with a
military drone overhead we realize we're
being tracked this is what has driven
tens of thousands of civilians to flee
their homes exposure isn't dropping the
Blitz appears designed to do just that
push people out and they're now cornered
in Italy province with nowhere else to
go
[Applause]
the military aircraft is still above us
one of the activists has been answered
I'm him as we scramble for cover the
regime isn't giving up they're firing at
us as we're trying to leave it Lib
civilians are enduring this every day in
this latest assault are you all right
below where are you here TF hit he's
been hit by shrapnel sky producer Martin
vowels bandages his wound
it doesn't appear too serious this
relentless shelling and the airstrikes
are endangering millions of people now
trapped in it lib but civilians are very
much in the firing line right now on day
well when you drop barrel bombs in the
middle of a city we don't get the
impression that they're concerned about
civilians because there's no backlash
and as long as there's no backlash it's
it's okay this is the same town which we
film from the overlooking hillside the
bombardment is comprehensive the
ceasefire deal brokered by Russia and
Turkey to safeguard civilians living
here is in tatters Bashar al-assad's
forces are again accused of dropping
barrel bombs from helicopters and the
u.s. is warning against using chemical
weapons
the rebels insist they've already been
hit by them the latest violence
escalated after HTS emerged as the
dominant rebel group the regime insists
they're terrorists an HTS warns there'll
be a massacre in Eid Lib
unless Assad stopped they repelled this
attack look you can see the Russian
aggression now these are the Russians
who support Bashar al-assad in killing
Muslims in Syria they support him in
killing civilians and attacking them
whole towns have emptied in this final
rebel outpost with civilians being
corralled into an increasingly small
corner of Italy and neither side showing
any sign of stopping the fighting Alex
Crawford Sky News mid Lib